and unfortunately we have even more
Marjorie Taylor green news this one
actually quite serious
while Marjorie Taylor green probably
stands no chance of becoming Speaker of
the House of Representatives and even
though she no longer has any committee
assignments she actually has put forth
legislation right now and this is
legislation
that would ban
gender affirming care
for lgbtq youth here in the United
States
let me read this this is from lgbtq
Nation
uh green has introduced a bill that
would make providing gender affirming
care for transgender minors a class C
felony
it would ban federal funds including
Medicaid funds from being used for
gender affirming care for transgender
people ban medical schools from teaching
about gender affirming care stop health
care plans under the Affordable Care Act
from funding gender affirming care and
ban anyone found to have performed
gender affirming care from immigrating
to the United States greens Bill lists a
number of procedures that aren't
performed on minors including castration
vasectomy any plastic surgery that
feminizes or masculinizes the facial
features and quote any placement of fat
or artificial implants in the gluteal
region
butt implants
because
Marjorie Taylor green somehow thinks
that we're
we're out there getting our kids butt
implants
and of course
to make it seem like she's not a bigot
she's not putting any of the criminality
on the transgender folks oh God no no
just the doctors and if you do any of
the things she's listed in the bill you
face 10 to 15 years in a federal prison
I'm sorry minimum of 10 years maximum of
25 not 15. so sorry
this is what they want
this is what they're trying to do
and again this wasn't just some proposal
she's put forward it's an actual piece
of legislation that she has introduced
in the house a house that of course is
not going to take up this legislation
right now
next year if Republicans win who knows
we've already seen by the way some of
the things that she has proposed in this
National legislation happened at the
state level
uh my Governor Ron DeSantis this week
came out and said no more Medicaid funds
for gender affirming care
this is what they want to do
and Marjorie Taylor green is laying the
framework for how they will do it as
soon as they get power
listen we got to take another quick
break again I am Faron cousins from Ring
of Fire sitting in for David packman and
we'll be right back